hey what's going on is Bill burned it's
time for the Monday morning podcast but
Monday March 13 2017 what's going on the
warrior how are you you know when I ask
you that every week how are but this did
you know this Monday I would really
night like to know how are you what's
good
Mandy what's going on with you you're
you're scaring me you know that's the
type of [ __ ] you can do when you're
abroad but if you're a guy you can't do
that you can't be like Mike what's going
on with me what's going on me what's
going on with you you're scaring me you
know was you taken by both his hands um
all right I got an hour here to do when
I gotta be honest with you I don't have
[ __ ] to say because my life has become
very compartmentalized being a dad here
daddy oh oh she's asleep downstairs man
she's [ __ ] awesome anybody who says
that being a parent is hard is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I'm not saying that's not
tedious
I'm not saying saying it's not like
walking around with a little [ __ ]
kettlebell all day long you know
especially if you [ __ ] up one of your
rotator cuffs I got to keep her in close
on the right hand side you know keep her
in tight Tiki Barber don't fumble um but
we just said around we listen to a lot
of music with her I was listening to
[ __ ] there was i listening to USA
just like they called malt shop oldies
it's basically like doo-wop from the
1950s and i kind of settled on that
channel and after a while i wanted to
turn the channel but i couldn't because
she was sleeping and the remote was like
across the table once they let's say
fall asleep dude it's just like you know
I don't care what position you're in
you're not moving because they're
[ __ ] sleeping right so I just sat
there and listened on a loop to all this
Dianna Dada Dinah and iRobot ever yep it
but but but but the people slowly going
out of my [ __ ] mind do ups great for
about four songs in a row and then it
just becomes the same song over and over
and [ __ ] it over again I was
[ __ ] for like a [ __ ] like an hour and
like half of those songs have been in
Scorsese movies you know it's always
like some guy's name and then the name
of a card you know so-and-so in the
Fleetwood something something in the
Belmonts Dion Annabelle much you gotta
love them they're still [ __ ] great
you know The Wanderer that [ __ ] song
is so applicable to anybody who didn't
get married you're in your 40s yeah well
I'm the type of guy who will never
settle down it makes you feel great
about the choice you made until if you
know you realize he's sang it in this
27c like oh [ __ ] was another one you
talk too much you talk too much you were
ramita dead you talk too much I think
has you even worried my pet it's looks
like they can't be the [ __ ] line but
they played it twice um speaking of
talking too much us what the [ __ ] I do
on this podcast oh I know what I could I
know what we actually had a date night
this is how much of a [ __ ] dad I'm
becoming you know still playing drums
you know schedule a helicopter thing so
you know I'm still trying to keep the
hobbies going but they're starting to
wobble on the sticks here so um we're
watching a commercial the other day no
you're watching real ah um the other day
and they always get to the [ __ ] the
last prize wheel fortune is so [ __ ] a
notoriously cheap first of all you're
basically spending this giant roulette
wheel and even on the real weapon
roulette wheel they got it you know
green zero and dumb the double green
zero and just that alone that alone will
completely [ __ ] you over
now obviously you guys hopefully of
listeners podcast long enough to know
that I am NOT a mathematician so I
cannot explain why but just having those
two will [ __ ] you over but what's that
face is the wheel of fortune I got like
[ __ ] I swear to god it's like
two or three bankrupts lose a turn just
constantly every two seconds you can see
that [ __ ] reverse flute they be they
go bankrupt and then it comes to their
big prize well they try to act like
they're gonna they're gonna throw down
some goddamn cash the last one it's so
[ __ ] difficult we're gonna guess some
letters for you we're gonna guess and
let us for it let me any guest of
letters for me you know the [ __ ]
answer
they act like it's weird when only like
one letter they only guess one letter
right and if you like okay give me give
me three [ __ ] letters in a vowel P um
f L and a and then it's always like
great guesses but I you're not gonna
like this V only got one letter it's
just like you know do the best you can
they always [ __ ] him over but this lady
this lady she actually did okay and she
won the prize she didn't do okay she
[ __ ] crushed it I can't manage said
keep your hands to yourself or something
like that was solving like no this is a
phrase like who would ever come up with
that on a [ __ ] game show keep your
hands to yourself was something on that
levels like semi-aggressive slash you
know date rape ii and it's on a [ __ ]
game show and she somehow got it there
is a point at the end of this right and
she ends up winning this [ __ ] to sega
some sort of monster some shit's not
Amiata
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was Suzuki
I have no [ __ ] idea it was a two-seat
sport car and immediately my first
thought was I looked at Neil's just like
he can't get a kidney and then she
laughed she was like ah look at you
becoming a dad am I gonna it was still
yoga cool but she was right you know not
becoming a dad I am a goddamn dad but
I'm not copping under those douchey dads
it talks about her parents whose talks
about how [ __ ] difficult their life
says it's [ __ ] awesome but having a
kid when you're in your 20s and you're
broke sucks you know but when you travel
in the country and they're paid your
money to talk about your dicks and do
[ __ ] dicks
talking about your dick and do [ __ ]
jokes it's not that bad
I'm only on the road like six days a
[ __ ] month you know let's say flying
at night early to go watch the [ __ ]
Bruins of Celtics of some [ __ ] our
schedules line up um none of that that
I'm here and she's cool as [ __ ] now she
doesn't really cry she only cries you
know needs a diaper change wants to be
held you know hungry
other than that she totally chills she's
met a bunch of people she doesn't freak
out with strangers one of the best
compliments I got you look uh your kids
really uh there's a really relaxed
healthy baby you know what I mean which
I'm [ __ ] psyched because that's what
I want it i obviously healthy but i want
a [ __ ] chill baby i don't want like I
basically don't want my kid to be like
me that's why I got to keep up with this
meditating cuz I didn't do it for a
minute and though the old gray mare she
ate I started [ __ ] going back to what
the [ __ ] I was you know like I [ __ ] I
was trying to you know sneak out of the
bedroom because I was gonna go work out
cuz I'm a [ __ ] fat cupcake eating
douche and um he just opens her eyes and
just goes could you change it really
quick I just stopped and I looked her
and I said you really need to work on
your good mornings
she's like sorry good morning and even
though I was right my tone was just it
was way too you know I was like that uh
I would say the Liam Neeson iam me and
Lisa Lisa on or whatever I I took it too
far which kills me that's why I loved
meditating because I don't take it too
far and if I make a point I'm still
right but when I don't meditate you know
I'd basically I walk around it as six
you know like saying ten is completely
losing your [ __ ] I walk around I'm just
walking down the street with a [ __ ]
balloon on my wrist at
six to a seven so it's very easy for me
to go right to ten unless I meditate
then that backs me down to about four or
three which still is pretty high but
it's kind of cutting my number almost in
half but what kills me is when I'm not
meditating and I'm up around a six or a
seven you know it gets that point even
if I'm right my reaction gives them this
this wiggle room you know some Bill
Clinton wiggle room to get the [ __ ] out
of it you know some Trump executive
order thing to go around some [ __ ] so
you know so I got a I got a key I gotta
stay on that type of [ __ ] dude speaking
of [ __ ] Neum Liam Liam listen
why can't you know it's one of those
[ __ ] goes by so [ __ ] quick you
never really even hear it
no bill we all hear it you don't know me
look I'm gonna get this guy's [ __ ]
name right he's great after hearing neom
oh no it's Liam Neeson he's first names
not Liam yes it is me and Lisa whatever
I'll never get that right I'm never
gonna get that [ __ ] right anyways the
[ __ ] head of hair on that son of a
[ __ ] um anyways I saw a [ __ ] great
movie this week so Saturday night
Saturday Saturday we go out and uh we
actually have a date night so we'll go
like our well get maybe like dinner in a
movie well basically turned about
appetizer and a drink and I'm sitting
there like you know I'm on the wagon I
can't do it he is like I'll just [ __ ]
have one cells like all right I'll have
one you know still on the wagon you know
I'm not like a [ __ ] alcoholic or I
just got to shut the whole thing off you
know what I mean so I had one I had a
cognac
Oh [ __ ] cognac and I just said you
know I just ordered the best one that
they had you know so it tasted amazing
but it was also like drinking gasoline
so I could only sip it
we got like an appetizer and then we
just sat there you know
shooting the [ __ ] it felt weird because
we had been out together in a while and
then we just started talking about our
daughter and looking at pictures of her
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like two addicts going out you know
what I mean at some point you're going
to start talking about Blow and how much
fun it is so then you know after that we
walked up the street we went to the
movie theater and we saw get out the
Jordan Peele féin film dude it was
[ __ ] them that was amazing you gotta
go see it I know isn't you know you know
there's always that movie over he's like
dude you got to go [ __ ] and see it and
it doesn't live up to the height it
lived up to the hype man it was [ __ ]
great what I loved what I loved about it
and what I love about all [ __ ] movies
like this is there was a bunch of [ __ ]
in there that you had left you to figure
out yourself and I saw the movie like
two three days ago Saturday night was a
Monday two days ago you know and I keep
even I'm driving I'm still thinking
about the movie I was like oh [ __ ] that
was this and this meant dad and this is
over here and this person's add like you
know was the perfect length the whole
thing and the acting and it was
unbelievable
through that [ __ ] guy swear to god
man that's like one of the most talented
people to come around in a long long
time you know to be that good at like
you know the characters they did on a
sketch show and the writing and then on
top of that you can direct I mean these
kind of [ __ ] limitless as far as this
talent goes but if you haven't seen it
yet before somebody ruins it you got to
go check it out all right there's my I
never do a movie plug so there you go
there's one for you so we ended up going
to that thing and I know what the [ __ ]
we did after that think we just came
straight home oh I know walked up to my
car and for some reason the [ __ ]
lights were on because cars are so
goddamn confusing like whatever the [ __ ]
my lights used to be was the automatic
he just turned the car on and they
[ __ ] come on
night like somehow the light cents night
[ __ ] creepy is that and I did the
manual one and now that it's on the
manual and I can't figure out where the
[ __ ] to put it so now I always have to
do it and now I'm like you know but you
know it kills me with today's technology
is I left those things on went and had a
drink and an appetizer and then saw like
a [ __ ] whatever whatever that movie
is 90 minutes I won 45 minute movie and
I came back my car still started up back
in the day you were [ __ ] everybody had
jumper cables do can give me a jump do
you mind if you kick hate to bother you
can give me a jump and was always like
the shittiest [ __ ] car ever and
you're like that man nah man I can't a
kid now you could just say no I can't
the big why not it's like well with
today's technology it's pointless for me
to ever look under my hood I just take
it down to the dealer and they deal with
everything I don't even know where the
battery is
I can guarantee you when I when I
[ __ ] lift up the hood I probably have
to remove something to get to one of the
terminals so I don't know why you're not
a member of triple-a but you know I
don't want to tell you and I leave and I
get my car and I Drive away from a
fellow American you know Stanley dude
what's going on with the [ __ ] Celtics
they've lost six of their last 11 games
that five and six and now the Wizards
The Wiz he's all down ease on down the
road
I don't really realized that till a
buddy of mine has been giving me [ __ ]
you know cuz the wizards have been
playing well against the Celtics and
just point great this year they slid
into second place and I just keep
thrashing about the name out like the
bullets is too violent you know which I
understand cuz this city was so violent
back in the day you know but to go from
being the bullets which I used to think
you know number one with the bullet
that's how I always looked at it well
faster than a speeding bullet
Superman [ __ ] I didn't think like you
know the team was embracing gang
violence out on the street it was like
pro crack
but such stupid sure I [ __ ] hate when
they so then what do they do what are
the soccer moms [ __ ] political correct
police who for some [ __ ] stupid
reason think that their digs progressive
people and think that they can just
always change words if we change words
it changes to perception no it doesn't
no it doesn't if your parents with dopes
racist [ __ ]
that's what you [ __ ] your kids going to
be that's it unless your kid is lucky
enough to interact with somebody within
the group that your parents used to
[ __ ] trash then maybe you got some
day like you don't just change a word
and it says fairy dust that sprinkles
over somebody's heart and you change
their thought it's so [ __ ] dumb all
it did was just become a way to lose
your job because you said the wrong
[ __ ] word and then what the person
who uses the word then they realize it
after they lose their job oh now I'm not
racist or homophobic it's so [ __ ]
dumb so they've gone right down to these
stupid [ __ ] team names I love how
they changed the bullets but not the
Redskins you know you got you got like
the [ __ ] victim if they haven't
changed the Redskins I'd be like yeah I
get that I get that like the Indians you
know it's like alright you know we
weren't from [ __ ] we weren't you know
Columbus didn't understand that there
was a real world this shit's even real
who the [ __ ] knows there was no tape
recorders this guy didn't have a [ __ ]
diary but other story was told was that
he was like nah man the world is [ __ ]
round this guy had the balls this guy
had the [ __ ] balls to start going
towards where they thought you'd go off
the edge of the earth in a [ __ ] boat
you know I don't know why the water
makes it more scarier but you know if
anybody just sat around thought about
Sarah the world is [ __ ] flat how
isn't the water just running off the
edges here do they not have counters and
sinks I guess they didn't do they have
plumbing at that point again you know
the Romans did
[ __ ] Ethan's banging each other in
the goddamn bathrooms they're whatever
they did ate till they puke rooms just
eat until you [ __ ] puke so I would
actually think well at the very least
even if it is flat the fact that there's
still water in the ocean there's got to
be land on the other side holding it in
right
but not old Christopher Columbus not old
Chrissy
he was like now [ __ ] that I'm gonna get
to the West Indies whatever the [ __ ] it
was I'm gonna get to India um going the
other way me [ __ ] sky the balls to
sail out that way sails out that way and
then anything so [ __ ] these people must
be Indian you know that's just sort of
like Oh Arab I thought you were Italian
I mean it's at that level of offensive
like I mean would you really get that
offended like now I'm [ __ ] Arab how
dare you but what you got against
Italians you [ __ ] sorry anyways um
speaking of which I don't understand all
these people going on to ancestry.com
why you would go to a [ __ ] website
and let them take a swab of your saliva
are you a [ __ ] dumber people oh my
god I didn't realize you know I'm also
Swahili whatever the [ __ ] why don't we
pick Swahili let's think of Romania I
didn't understand I was also Hungarian
great now I know why I like goulash
one-eighth of the time at this point
you're so [ __ ] far removed and I
don't understand why people are sitting
there acting like there's any sort of
culture there isn't all right it's just
like what I saw in the greater Phoenix
area there's a new patch of land you
know you're [ __ ] clear it out you put
a bunch of houses down and then you slam
down Oh a [ __ ] strip ball sorry I got
to do this podcast before
my daughter wakes up here um yeah they
slap down a [ __ ] strip mall and just
continue to progress that that's
basically you know then there's a
Cheesecake Factory they get a frozen
yogurt place and that's what it's become
okay there's no there's no culture left
is there I mean that is the culture this
sounds like one of the douchey talk show
right now there is no culture this is
what needs to stop we have to stop these
strip malls all right do you have a
solution I know I don't I just don't
like CBS anchored strip malls there was
a bunch of people out the other day you
know you know when you just have like
[ __ ] to do I go Saturday right and it's
rained a bunch when we were out here and
some [ __ ] idiot politician said the
droughts over it's like no it isn't it's
never over it's just in a good place
right now when is it gonna rain again
you don't know so now you gonna let
people go back to taking long [ __ ]
showers I never do that out here I shut
I turn on and shut off the water like
[ __ ] five times when I take a shower
I turn it on you know get yourself wet
you know and then you shut it off shut
yourself up then you turn it back on
rinse yourself off you shut it off and
that's it so says standing there under
the cascading water you don't like you
some sort of God and I like to think a
lot of people try to do that at least my
wife doesn't she [ __ ] turns a thing
on [ __ ] walking around you know she's
one of those chill people especially she
doesn't think about [ __ ] like that you
know I guess what I'm trying to say is
I'm a better person than my wife and I
don't know how to bring that up if you
guys know a good way to word it like how
can I basically say you know what it is
honey I guess at the end of the day I'm
just I'm just a better person than you
are I just already pictured her role in
her eyes anyways um the [ __ ] was my
point all right yeah so Indians okay
that's like [ __ ] that's almost kind
of funny
like now you [ __ ] dope you like 6,000
miles away from what you think you are I
guess it was probably funny at first he
started chopping people's arms off
because they couldn't [ __ ] get some
gold for the holes in his teeth
and who the [ __ ] am I to say what's
offensive way but you would think that
[ __ ] what that would be at the top of
the [ __ ] list over bullets you know
it's the worst one the fact that the
Tampa Bay Devil Rays are now just the
Rays you know that's when you know you
got a move that's when you just sit like
wait a minute
are there enough Jesus freaks in this
area that the local team has to appease
their you know hocus pocus [ __ ]
I mean Devil Rays that isn't that isn't
that an actual name it's like some sort
of stingray I have no idea maybe it is
maybe it isn't
all I know is that that guy's first name
is Liam that sounds too close like lime
like Lyme disease alright devil ray
there we go yeah let me see here all I'm
seeing is pictures of [ __ ] stingrays
giant ones with the [ __ ] you know
like they're flying through the water if
somebody can explain to me how that
makes you move forward when they make
you go up to the surface do these things
that [ __ ] gigantic they're badass
look at the thing it's getting air it's
jumping out of the water unless somebody
photoshopped it I got to go video now
they just change it to the Rays we just
DeRay incredible flying rays so I guess
devil ray was the nickname oh Jesus
Christ I don't need a commercial I do
the commercials not you on the west
coast there's always some [ __ ]
English accent and the shark plus it's
the BBC sorry
oh Jesus that what are they shown that I
somehow I got a [ __ ] Pelican 20
abnormally large animals that actually
exist this is how you [ __ ] go down
open you go down just like a what are
they called to go down the [ __ ]
rabbit hole let's see come on man oh
that was as tough as a school of them
I'm an [ __ ] right as it [ __ ] got
good Jesus those things ugly as [ __ ] huh
all right so they're dead they're in a
helicopter I imagine they're flying over
this this whole school of them it's like
a [ __ ] devil ray orgy that's why I
bet the other ones that like more like
what do they call it for just monogamous
these things are already a [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of each other and the local
Jesus freaks down in Clearwater Florida
they couldn't have it nah they fly out
of the [ __ ] water they're not too
graceful with the with the landing there
alright I'll repost that [ __ ] video
in case you want to watch that while you
listen to me ramble about it um yeah
they changed it to the Rays the Tampa
Bay Rays the Tampa Bay Devil Rays two
syllables two syllables okay they went
from 4/4 time to 3/4 they turned their
[ __ ] team into a wall I don't know
how do you know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about can I can I read can read
you guys want you'd listen to me read
out loud hey everybody it's time to feel
better about your the brain you were
blessed with just sit right here can
somebody explain to me why it's not at
the font I need I like a nice [ __ ] 18
font that's good for me alright Oh
dollar shaped over everybody oh Jesus
Christ there's no reason to use a cheap
disposable razor your stupid [ __ ] Oh pay
a ridiculously high price for gimmicky
for a gimmicky thing it's got a laser
pointer with 17 blades
you don't need to do it make the smart
choice and join Delilah shade Club dude
before Dollar Shave Club
it was either save money and get a
painful shave from a disposable like
ones they give away for free at the gym
which felt like shaving with a piece of
glass or pay a fortune for the latest
gimmick t-shaped breakthrough you don't
need like a laser chin detector or has
17 blades as I told you before the sweet
spot was two blades two plates was
perfect nothing shaved like the two
blade three blade stinks that's when it
get the gets too big you can't get
underneath you knows Dollar Shave Club
it's the best of both worlds a premium
shave at a disposable price get a
clothes smooth shave every time god damn
it if you can't beat the convenience of
the price of the club I don't know what
the [ __ ] could tell you you haven't
tried Dollar Shave Club yet you're
missing out it's an amazing shave and an
affordable price if you haven't figured
that out yet like they haven't said it
27 [ __ ] times are they saying it one
time for every blade you don't need
there's no smarter choice on the market
right now they're giving away a
one-month trial of any of their razors
for one dollar with free shipping and
after that it's just a few bucks a month
there's no long term commitments no
hidden fees you know your girlfriend
won't [ __ ] around on you and you can
cancel whenever you want
get your $1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / let's tell the Sheikh club.com / /
oh here's our friends oh here we go it's
old zip cruder
are you hiring well are you do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates you don't do you but you
don't want to admit it to anybody so
when no one's around you put your head
down in your desk you quietly cry to
yourself wishing that you were a child
again your parents were taking you out
for an ice cream because you can't deal
with the pressures of the world well I
got it I got a solution for you posting
a job in one place
enough to find quality candidates you
stupid [ __ ] you want to find the perfect
hire what though yeah you need to post
your job on all the top job sites and
now you can't with zip ah
Crudup calm you can post your job to 200
plus job sites including social media
networks like the Facebook and the
Twitter all with a single click look at
said single dick - [ __ ] pervert with
giant keys you know sticking his helmet
on the keyboard find candidates in any
city or industry nationwide just roll
well just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip
recruiters easy to use interface no
juggling emails have calls to your
office quickly screen candidates rate
them judge them put them in a box and
hire the right person fast nice days
find out today why zip has been used by
Fortune 100 companies and thousands of
small and medium-sized businesses and
right now my listeners my listeners and
anybody else they sold this to can post
jobs on zip recruiter for free by going
to zip recruit accom / / @ zip recruiter
dot-com / / one more time try it for
free go to zip dot-com / / alright how
many more of these [ __ ] things I got
two more left going hang in there hang
in there with me
it's helix everybody hellix you're
unique you're special
no you're not you're drowning in
mediocrity when are you going to find
your voice what are you going to spread
your wings like a devil ray come out of
the water and deal with your [ __ ]
eyeballs that hang out the side of your
[ __ ] head come out of the water and
show people who you are and then belly
flop back into it alright you're unique
okay yeah there's something about you I
guess you know I guess if I talked to
your mother she could find something
you don't walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else show chant or sleep
like anyone else so why the [ __ ] is your
mattress one size fits all they've ever
thought about this of course you haven't
who the [ __ ] has time to think about
this because a truly customized mattress
will cost you five to ten thousand bucks
Jesus Christ does it come with a couple
of who is until now
go to hell exhale except calm answer a
few simple questions do a saliva swab
and they'll run a 3d biomechanical model
mode L of your body through the
proprietary algorithms they develop with
the help of the world's leading error
ergonomics and biomechanics experts
they're going to make a [ __ ] robot
that's what they're going to do it
they're not going to do this I bet helix
is going to [ __ ] sell that that for
[ __ ] proprietary algorithm of your
goddamn nutsack and next thing you know
there's going to be a [ __ ] lifelike
robot walking around with an exact
replica of your junk but I'm gonna tell
you right now you're gonna sleep like
you've never slept before alright
you know why because hellix customers
helix report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality how they figure
that out I have no idea
how can you [ __ ] take notes while
you're sleeping I guess when they wake
up they feel you and if you want to
prove your [ __ ] sleep by 30 percent
lay off the booze you [ __ ] drunk save
money on the mattress if you lay off the
book maybe this is this is the [ __ ]
mattress for drunks so as much as you
hungover
you're off set it with this great
mattress I'm gonna get one of these
things and for couples oh now they're
getting freaky they customized each side
of the mattress oh they went the other
way they customized each side of the
mattress you know that's for someone in
a loveless marriage if you notice that
your side of the bed isn't it's you know
if you're annoyed that your wife likes
soft magic that's [ __ ] over and I
like the hard mattress that's it just go
start sleeping on the couch and when she
goes to bed
you know start trolling for Internet
[ __ ] social media that's what you
should do but anyways your mattress
arrives at your door in about a week and
shipping is 100% free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
Alex you have a hundred nights to try it
out gross and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free disgusting
and give you a hundred percent refund no
questions asked I always picture mr.
white and Jesse Pinkman showing up in a
hazmat suit you know we're here for your
mattress and you won't even touch it at
that point yeah it's in the back
good luck to you go to helix sleep talk
comm slash burn get $50 off you ordered
that's HELOCs sleep calm / / one more
time hey helix sleep calm / / lastly but
not leastly MV MT watches the company
started by two Broke college kids I've
never understood that line hey we're
flat broke you want to start a company
absolutely they wanted to wear stylish
watches but they couldn't afford them so
they started their own watch company did
they just solve the homeless problem you
know I'm [ __ ] living outside I can't
afford a house so I went out and I
bought one no more homeless guy how is
this like how you started built a
following launched into a podcast
YouTube radio etc oh I guess awesome oh
you know what this reminds me when I
started out like a comedian I didn't
have any joke so I sat down I wrote
something then I went up on stage and uh
you know I did okay does that remind you
watches all right movement watches
started at just $95 at a department
store bomb sorry 95 movement watches
started just 95 dollars
dot-dot-dot at a department store you're
looking at four to five hundred bucks
move it watches no move it figured out
that by selling online they were able to
cut out the middleman and retail
markley figured it out everybody knows
that Jesus Christ these guys are
geniuses providing the best
quality/price classic design quality
construction and style minimalism over 1
million watches sold in over a hundred
and 60 countries
that's almost 50,000 watches in each
country get 15% off today with free
watches and free returns by going to
movement watches dot-com / / this watch
has a really clean design seriously I've
been getting compliments ever since I
put mine on now is the time to step up
your watch game go-to movement watches
dot-com / bird join the movement now
what a [ __ ] would they say that I'm
walking around wearing them I would wear
that if I was like 20 years younger okay
let me tell you something if you're in
your late [ __ ] 40s and you can't
afford a [ __ ] you can't afford a
decent what decent watch cuz I know I
don't go for the flesh you know what I
mean I don't I don't understand that
dead [ __ ] I mean I get it I guess I get
that Rolex thing that hacky thing I got
a Rolex as you can see I've made my
dreams come true I'm a man of the world
you know there's a lot of guys out there
you know my dad always said a man should
own a nice watch what else did he say
you know what else did he say that was
so [ __ ] deep baby you know it maybe
had a nice calm relaxed relaxing person
in your life maybe you did I'm always
jealous of that when I see like calm
families they gotta be bored shitless
though there's gotta be you know what I
would actually be willing to guess that
the child that is more likely to just go
[ __ ] nuts you don't I mean take out
the family car you know throw a hatchet
over somebody's head it's gonna come
from a calm family after a while that's
stupid no it isn't I'm just saying it's
possible just the [ __ ] monotony of it
like you ever go to Disneyland and you
[ __ ] worn out and then you just
started hearing it's a small world and
it just keeps going over and over again
and you slowly feel yourself like losing
your sanity that right there is why I
don't believe in heaven or hell you know
I mean I just don't believe in it it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense you know
like if Heaven was if it was just heaven
the whole [ __ ] time heaven would
eventually become hell because it would
just be so [ __ ] nice and everybody
would just be walking around isn't
that's great oh my god it's good can you
believe how great this is
this is just [ __ ] great it's like
every [ __ ] day and at some point
you'll be like I did it it's [ __ ]
great you know like what do you do for
the rest of your [ __ ] life you're
just sitting there and it's always the
same it's just awesome it never rains
there's no disappointments there's no
challenges there's no funny stories to
tell anymore hey you remember remember
remember that time when it was awesome
yeah it's always awesome right then if
you're in Hell I want fire now laughs
I've got him on fire and fire after a
while you know what yeah I'm on fire I
can't yell anymore this has just become
normal I don't even remember what my
[ __ ] life was like before I got here
I don't know I guess halwa hell you can
actually see how that would suck I don't
get heaven I don't wanna [ __ ] be like
you know at some point if some happens
to happen I'm so as I'm riding around in
my [ __ ] all angel white bicycle at
some point you got to get a flat right
then immediately somebody would be there
to help help you out they'd just be
saying a bunch of nice [ __ ] to you I
would slowly just start crying I would
just whisper at some point right Jesus
thank you for thinking
get I know this is weird I understand
and I'm not I'm not trying to be that
guy who's not appreciative but could you
just lean up but you just call me a [ __ ]
or something could you [ __ ] just slap
me with his sandal you know you just
imagine the look on his face as he just
sits there you know not saying anything
as you talk yourself into a corner and
she's sort of looking at you know people
look at you when they go from one eye to
the other right eye you left eye you
right out your left eye any like this
[ __ ] trying to get my head
right now the Son of God is trying to
get in my [ __ ] head then you got to
explain that to the boss's son why you
don't like heaven nothing you don't like
it but it's just like can you make it
rain every once in a while can they be
that dog that's just [ __ ] barking
right as I'm going to sleep come can we
just have that does every [ __ ] dog
have to behave itself why can't I say
that word Jesus why can't I say that
word might disrupt in it what are you
gonna do now send me down to hell it's
over I already passed the test all right
can somebody be annoyed with [ __ ]
something up here look at everybody look
at all these [ __ ] goddamn smiles on
their faces
it's creeping Jesus I don't know would
you want to [ __ ] be like it's like
you joined a cult
all of these [ __ ] on me if I was
running [ __ ] I would make religion
illegal
it would just be [ __ ] I would just
take it all away from everybody you know
that's what I would do I would have I
would have a [ __ ] crew robots you
know to infiltrate every [ __ ]
religion and then at when I made it
illegal they would join the radicalized
people in every group right and then
they would just wipe them all out you
know they need have to listen to the
whining and the crying of people that
remembered [ __ ] religion and all just
you just take the whole [ __ ] thing
away
and the new religion is hey I don't know
what the [ __ ] happens after you die you
know but you know let's be nice to each
other then that's it okay no walking on
water no never running out of fish part
and C's I don't know about anybody
else's religion I know what the [ __ ] but
I know there's always some [ __ ] crazy
thing that you know didn't happen and
everybody acts like it happened it
didn't happen it was painted on a
[ __ ] cave wall and somebody
elaborated on it I don't know I get rid
of it personally I'm just I'm just
talking for myself personally I would
get rid of it be by the way guess what
I'm doing on March 29th out here in Los
Angeles all right if you're if you're in
Los Angeles and you're a Guns and Roses
fan and you like reading their books
about the band I've read every [ __ ]
one of them
I read slashes I read Stephen Adly I
read the kid from Canter's do you know
knew the band took all the pictures I
have that [ __ ] book and recently I
don't know I don't know when she put it
out but Deana Adler Stephen Adler's mom
wrote a book sweet child of mine and
especially if you if you should read
this you should read Stephens first you
know you get his version of the hell he
went through as an addict and then you
get his mother's version which is
unbelievable and you know what would be
[ __ ] amazing is if you could go down
and meet her at a book signing it blinds
Noble at the Grove on March 29th I
believe it starts at 7:00 p.m. he go
down there and you could [ __ ] meet
the mother of the best [ __ ] one of
the best drummers the 80s my personal
opinion you don't be even more [ __ ]
amazing is if all of them came on my
podcast and I got to interview him Oh is
there a special Monday morning pot
is coming up this week would that be
incredible what would it be like if
Steven Adler you guys all know how much
I [ __ ] love him
his mother Deanna Adler and then their
brother Jaime Adler all came on my
[ __ ] podcast what would that be like
would be I like if they all came on at
the same time and then with this big
happy family that just sat there
interrupting each other and you felt
like you were at their [ __ ] dinner
table how [ __ ] cool would that be if
I did a podcast like that well it's
going to happen
it already happened I already recorded
it and I'll wait to you guys listen to
it but I had so much fun with them and
their mother is an absolute
salt-of-the-earth sweetheart and she has
a book signing and she's all excited /
nervous that no one's going to show up
you know as you know same way when I put
out a special what if nobody watches it
so I'm gonna be hyping this right up
until March 29th it would be such a
great thing if there was a bunch of
people down there I'm gonna be down
there standing in line with the rest is
probably get down there I don't know
probably like around uh a dish I think
it starts at like 7:00 but I'll be down
there around ages cuz I got I get some
[ __ ] thing I'm taping right before
but um yeah I did a special podcast I
got to meet Steven Adler and I'm still
[ __ ] freaking out and and I'll wait
to you guys listen the interview and
then I'll tell you all the [ __ ] cool
stories all right here we go let's let's
plow ahead here
oh my Bruins beat the [ __ ] floor is
Oh at that little [ __ ] prayer of a
shot at the end not a prayer just put it
on net somehow found its way to the back
of the net Bruins pick up a huge two
points Bruins are playing great and as
are the Canadians which I don't like the
Canadians but I'm happy for Chloe
Julianne you know and I'm actually you
know what I think the Bruins might have
been right to make a move at this point
I think it's just one of those things
with coaching after a while even if the
person is great even if they won your
cup it's just it's just part of coaching
at some point they just
Jogi the door but um we're playing great
we look a lot better than we did so I
think maybe both it's worked on the
[ __ ] Canadians are playing better
with Claude Julien all my friends in
this business who I had fans they keep
texting me saying that they're loving
the guy so I guess it worked out for
everybody so there you go and cloak went
from original [ __ ] six to an original
six there you go alright so anyways
let's plow ahead here um let's read some
of the some of the [ __ ] whatever your
columns for this week the the questions
alright DDP yoga hey Bill first of all
thank you very much for your
consistently amazing podcast well thank
you for listening thank you for doing
what you do sir or ma'am I absolutely
love it to be honest with you I feel
like it's getting it's I feel like
getting it for free is too much I'd
gladly pay five to ten bucks a month for
all the content you're releasing you
don't need to do that I'm [ __ ] I'm
doing great with the advertising you
know that's why I [ __ ] around during the
advertising because that's how I [ __ ]
make money but I know you guys are going
to fast forward through it unless I keep
peppering it with Fox and [ __ ] that's
it's a very simple formula anyhow he
said I want to get in touch and address
your self-proclaimed dadbod have you
ever heard of or looked into DDP yoga uh
if not maybe the name Diamond Dallas
Page rings a bell former WCW wrest
wrestler and all-around great guy after
leaving the wrestling business he
devoted himself to getting his body back
in peak condition even through rasslin
even though wrastlin is is quote fake it
definitely takes a toll yeah they beat
the [ __ ] out of their bodies long story
short he went from being a guy who
wouldn't be caught dead in a yoga studio
to trying it after all else failed to
develop his own system in helping
thousands of people completely
revitalize their lives and I can tell
you from personal experience it's
[ __ ] great no
[ __ ] no fluff knowing structures
structures calmly whispering about
chaperone alignment so they say
chakra chakra it's about consistently
performing the physical and mental
exercises that will have you operating
at your best this is a commercial
healing nagging aches and pains
increasing your endurance gaining mental
clarity etc like I said no fluff here's
the video that got me to take a chance
on it it's not too late for you Billy
I hope you'll check it out thanks again
for the goddamn podcast all the best to
you and your family that actually read
like a commercial but you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] it's a physical
fitness thing and so many people have
taken yoga and done it in a different
way you know because there is that thing
if you're really like a wound up psycho
to go into a yoga class and the tone
with which that they speak is a little
jarring you know to be in your car go go
you [ __ ] can't the lightest weight
could have made it to then being like
how is everyone feeling today I know the
traffic was kind of bad I hope I hope
you're not bringing that energy in here
as they're slowly walking around
lighting these smelly [ __ ] things you
know and as they're talking the person
next he just goes
and immediately you just want to like I
don't know just slowly roll up your mat
and just walk out like I can't like I
get it I get that I need to chill out
but I can't feel like you know you know
what it just becomes like this asexual
thing where everybody's just kind of
like hey man we just can you know
everybody's just like we're all like one
you know we're like plants that's a
little [ __ ] jarring I'll give it a
shot I've actually been meaning to do it
because I keep having setbacks with my
[ __ ] shoulder which is really
frustrating but um most of it is diet so
whenever I get in shape the first thing
I do is I cut out the booze and all I
really need to go I need to go like four
to six days without any booze even just
having that one cognac didn't really do
anything
like I had the one and then immediately
my body's like hey why don't we have 15
more but I had to go to the movie and
then I was fine
and then the second I'm in there the
buzz starts to wear off I think I'll
thank God I didn't have 15 more not to
mention I got a drive right I'm gonna
give it a shot I just think if I did
yoga I'd have to do in the morning
before the little one wakes up um she's
so [ __ ] awesome dude I'm telling you
right you'll never regret it I guess you
know when you're Gretta if you have a
kid with somebody that you're not love
with I guess that that would suck but at
the end of the day the kids still
awesome it's a hell of a door price I'll
tell you that right oh I'll tell you all
right trans wrestling hey that I'm
already gonna watch this if this is what
I think it is a that Billy boo did you
hear the story about the trans girl
going through home hormone treatment who
was still wrestling girls in high school
his / her defense is that it's a low
dose of testosterone and it does not
allow for any competitive advantage wait
a minute isn't that what HGH is that's
human growth hormone well I guess they
don't take human growth hormone running
away I don't know what kind of hormones
they take having said that I'm not sure
let my daughter wrassle a girl who had
any edge at all even if it's a tiny bit
of extra strength it could be the
difference in breaking a bone thoughts
would you let your daughter wrestle in
that situation uh yeah yeah I would then
they're gonna break a [ __ ] bone you
know what I mean how many times the
people break a bone in wrestling does
that really happen they just [ __ ] on
each other the whole time it's like you
know like that official level [ __ ] not
not not the function the stone-cold [ __ ]
that the actual official college [ __ ]
it's like it's a competitive spooning
you don't I mean it's like one person is
trying to spoon with the other person
the other person is like I want to be
this the Spooner not the spoon II that's
basically what's going on they don't
like you no no I would be concerned
about that yeah I'm one of those debts
with the kids crying go away you know
she's already half a guy I'd be driving
as far as I know she's still a girl so
suck it up you want to be the best well
then you've got a wrestle half of -
that's it - sick I don't want to hear
another word out of you I'd be like that
whether you embrace the opportunity to
be like well here we go if this is
actually a [ __ ] advantage all this is
going to do is make me better you don't
I mean and then you can go up there and
give your record 27 and Oh against 100%
chicks and what did two against someone
who was half a dude right you got to
embrace it
I mean what is that person supposed to
do there's not enough [ __ ] people
that are going through what the [ __ ]
she's going through to fit on either
side you know I think is I think it's a
cool thing [ __ ] I won't gives a [ __ ]
look there's already going to be that
[ __ ] monster anyways so some woman's
going to walk in there and just going to
be blessed
with frontier strength you know what I
mean chopping wood strength there's
gonna be that person anyways I mean I
guess if she was actually if she was
trying to get a scholarship and a loss
could potentially affect it um maybe but
I gotta be honest with you I think I
don't know I would be as a father I'd be
like cycling I'll see how you do but
this is actually an advantage this is a
great [ __ ] opportunity do you become
a for you to become a better wrestle
there's no money on the line who gives a
[ __ ]
let's go let me tell you something
brother
come to Saturday when my daughter
wrestles against at half a dude what are
you gonna do when these pythons run wild
on you I I get up for it I wouldn't give
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it um Yemeni guy in Europe so
persons from Yemen Yemeni young Yemen
and Yi how the [ __ ] do you say that guy
in Europe all right hey Bill
I'm a Yemeni guy who is Beth I hope you
saying that right no disrespect here
who's been living in Europe for the past
six [ __ ] years although everything is
going alright I want to ask your advice
because I can relate to your personality
hang on a second sir or ma'am I want to
[ __ ] figure out whether from assuming
you're from Yemen what is Yemeni what is
a Yemeni whom to whom is he is a
Yemenite oh you why did that all
disappear what is a Yemeni come on all
right
relating to Yemen or its people holy
[ __ ] I was right that's a nice flag I
got a nice flag I like just the three
bars I'm a big three bar flag guy
France Italy Ireland Yemen all right
what do you guys think of the new
Russian flag I kind of like the old one
the old one was this [ __ ] all red with
that sickle I thought I thought that
that one was [ __ ] dope the new ones
all right
what is it red white and blue holy [ __ ]
they got the same colors as us that what
is it something like that I don't know I
was watching this whole thing about
Vladimir Putin poisoning these guys and
[ __ ] allegedly I have no idea so
watching it on 60 minutes so it's got to
be true right tick tick tick tick tick
all right Yemeni guy in Europe I've been
over there for the last six [ __ ]
years I want to ask you a question cuz I
can relate your personality my family
has been living in a war zone in Yemen
for the past two years our old house our
old house there was bombed and my father
was inside but the lucky bastard came
out without a scratch I miss them and
wish I could help them but that's kind
of not possible now
alright before I already feel like this
is going to be way over my head before
that I lost some good old friends that I
knew for more than 10 years because of
some stupid incidents was beaten by a
gang of more than 15 men in Malaysia on
a trip there for no reason and my 2-year
ex girlfriend at the time cheated on me
with their current borough boyfriend is
this [ __ ] amazing this guy's on the
other side of the planet in the exact
same [ __ ] gang violence and your [ __ ]
girl got sick of you and [ __ ] bang
somebody else cheated on me with her
current boyfriend while I was on that
trip I guess to Malaysia and didn't have
the decency to break up with me before
that she was my first ah you know what
are you going to do people are young
they don't know how to break up so they
wait till you go to Malaysia and they
[ __ ] somebody I mean this is a a
time-honored tradition of how to break
up with somebody alright so if you're
with your first love what have we
learned
do not go by yourself to Malaysia I
don't know how many
times I brought that up on this podcast
you cannot go to [ __ ] Malaysia alright
I just graduated from college I have a
beautiful girlfriend which I love and
feel blessed with what I have I know
that I was an [ __ ] at certain moments
of my life but I have changed a long
time ago and I'm still trying to be more
honest clear and focused well welcome to
the club sir I'm currently looking for a
job in Germany and will try to apply
after that for a German passport which
will make my life much easier and allow
me to start a company and sustain myself
without being dependent on others
exactly you want to work for yourself I
know that you have lived certain moments
in your life where you were faced by
challenged faced with challenges that
might have taught a lesson but at the
same time left a mark on your
self-confidence how did you empower
yourself and what advice would you give
a young man like me confronting life's
challenges
that's it [ __ ] congratulations on
your baby and [ __ ] you now there's a guy
ok who speaks at least 3 languages and
still is able to break balls isn't that
amazing
he's probably speaks Yemeni Yemenite
Yemen Asian whatever the [ __ ] he speaks
right he snows that one he's in Germany
so he's got to speak that language won't
revile you in this space right and he
can also speak English um how did I
empower myself uh I used to just say
[ __ ] out loud to myself you know when I
would feel the dark cloud of doubt
coming in I would just you know it took
me a while but I would I would but I
mean I wasn't facing what you were
you're facing being an immigrant so I
mean you're facing way more than I did
and the but the fact that uh I know
you're trying to become a better person
you know you know to reach out for help
and all that I think I my gut says
you're going to be fine well you have to
do in general is when the doubt comes in
you got to beat the [ __ ] out of it you
know yeah after the biggest thing is is
that you're conscious
that this of the self-doubt so once
you're conscious of it you can then
address it it's when you when you're
really young and you're not conscious of
it and that thought comes in and then
you start dwelling on it and then it
just washes over your whole body and you
can literally you know have a [ __ ]
panic attack would you have to do I did
anyways is you know you try to cancel it
out with the positive thought I know
this sounds like hokey [ __ ] but I used
to just say [ __ ] out loud I read some
book one where and it started off with
like I would just be walking down the
street you know walking by other people
and I would just really be just spilling
a [ __ ] dad
[ __ ] that he's looking at me like I was
nuts but I was like [ __ ] that negative
thought man wouldn't yell it but I would
I would kind of just say [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that no it isn't no what is it right no
it won't or whatever the hell it was and
then it just became like when I moved to
New York and trying to get in at the
club's I knew I was going to get in but
you know the day to day just seemed like
like impossible and you know the club
owners and everything and you know and
some of them were cool and others
enjoyed the fact that you were desperate
and just really enjoyed that position of
power over you and I would walk out of
the club dejected you know I was afraid
you know am I going to run out of money
I don't have a job right now I'm doing
these driving back to Massachusetts to
[ __ ] feature and dick dougherty's
rooms that was not barely covering you
know living in New York every time you
stepped outside you blew 20 bucks 30
bucks you know and I just four sides
started I what I said was I'm tougher
than you New York is that what I would
say is hokey as that sound that's what
they you know the city would kick me in
the balls and then I would just mumble
that to myself sometimes like six times
in a row
until I got that thought on my head and
I would just say and then I would just
pick I'm going to get in the clubs I'm
going to get in and I'm gonna make a
living I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna be
fine everything's going to be fine
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that I mean
something like that that's what I had to
do and and then it just you know and
that continues throughout your [ __ ]
life and you know then you get to my age
you know and I'm doing great and
everything but there's also there's
always your mortality around the [ __ ]
corner and how I've kind of mentally
dealt with death the inevitable death is
that like that I just think it's going
to be a great experience you don't mean
that
I don't think anything bad happens to
you when you die either you just go into
the ground and then that's it and then
that's it
you know you got to be a person on this
planet as opposed to like a [ __ ]
mosquito you got the best [ __ ]
experience hopefully you did and then
that's it it's [ __ ] over or if you
become something else I just don't think
that is bad you know I just don't think
that doesn't make any sense that it
would then just be bad I don't know I
hope that helps you I got a little off
the rails there so what I would say is
you just baby step your way you know and
like for me making it as a comedian was
like a 20-year [ __ ] 15 20 year
process I was obviously I was not the
overnight I didn't have the hook I
didn't have any of that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I just basically every day you know was
[ __ ] hacking at the tree until it
came down and you know you just don't
quit he's just that's it you just don't
quit you don't give it a negative
thought and every day you just
can take a few steps towards it and then
one day just wake up and your way you
wanted to be and you're like I gotta
[ __ ] did that happen to you funny you
don't feel any different
you know so but she'll be alright thing
you're gonna be alright you know you
speak three different [ __ ] languages
you can break balls in English I mean
you sound you sound like you got a great
sense of humor
and you're trying together you're gonna
be fine just say that to yourself I'm
going to be fine this is going to work
out and then that's it then you can try
to [ __ ] help somebody else out along
the way alright last one here
documentary recommendations Hey Oh Billy
Oh Billy beatdown I was wondering if you
had heard of the this new documentary
that just came out called ice guardians
it's about the history of enforcers and
hockey and I would love to hear your
take on it if you haven't seen it I
watch all of these [ __ ] things I
haven't seen it but I watched the
trailer and it looked great I don't know
about the name ice guardians that sounds
somewhere between a superhero movie and
a musical a musical on ice coming to
Madison Square Garden it's ice guardians
Fosse hands skating around the ice um he
said thanks for all the laughs and for
always making me feel better about the
way I read things out loud thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself here's a link to the
trailer ok I'll send out this link into
the trailer by the way I'm going to be
at the South by Southwest on Tuesday I'm
flying in Tuesday I'm doing a podcast
with al Madrigal for all things comedy
Network and then I'm flying right back
out that night that's it boom doing a
pot landing doing a podcast jump it back
on the plane and flying back that's my
dedication to the goddamn network and
also my dedication to [ __ ] coming
back to see my daughter that's it and
after that I got three days a Monday a
Tuesday a Wednesday at The Improv in San
jose cruz i think that that's my that'll
be my [ __ ] uh that'll be my month
that's it
alright thanks for listening to podcast
go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday and I
think that's it that is it all right go
[ __ ] yourself